Times changed, and so did Pithecanthropus.
His skull grew loftier and broader.
Arms, legs, and hands became more human.
Synanthropus, Florenscombe or Montmoren Man,
Neanderthal Man, Solo Man,
Desian Man, didn't stay around for long.
Say that laughter is a characteristic of man,
at least of kids.
And so, I think, of course.
Ah, morning, son.
Oh, how big he's grown just since this morning,
but I'd slow him down a little if I were you.
Merce, heavens, what on?
Yeah, it's just the right spot.
Hey, you're quite right.
What a pleasant spot.
Dash, second, I have an idea.
Well, boys, you've got quite a catch.
Hmm?
Are these rocks here?
Another one of his bright ideas.
Oh, yeah, just how many uses this tool has.
The bifacial or two-sided cutting tool, useful for a variety of tasks.
The hand axe, which would become the all-purpose tool.
Cleaver, ancestor of the knife.
And maestro feels the call of future generations.
We're leaving now.
Well thanks, I'd rather stay with Maestro.
You're right son, you're a smart boy.
Can't you see he's busy?
I know he'll be an artist, right?
Huh?
Not so fast.
It's my drift, they're my hunting grounds here, get that straight.
Now get the ding-dong out of here, you'll have me to deal with.
Listen, you can't scare us bullies, so there.
Swat down this pest, you flea.
Show 'em what you're made of, sick'em boy.
One piece.
Right now, what's holding things up, huh?
About the bashing his brains, chief.
He shall have his terrain, that's all.
We'll set the border here.
Yeah, but listen, Chief, can't we keep the animals?
Don't forget, the beasties are ours. That's my last offer.
Perhaps I could propose that we share.
If you want to pick out the best one,
pick that one.
What about that one, Chief? He won't obey.
You gotta maintain respect, Chief. Hey, Chief, you gotta maintain respect.
Get out of here. Go on, just get out of here.
Me? But why? I didn't do nothing.
Runt, you're banished.
That's not right.
That's life, folks.
It was a real piece of junk.
Let me have a try. It's my turn.
I'll use mine. Thanks, anyway.
That's a great tool.
Sure is. He's a real chip off the old block.
Go find young Pierre, huh?
Your pop wants you.
There.
No, that's much too big for me.
How's this?
Proud of you, my son. That's a fine job.
That's better.
Change your tune.
He'd gotten rid of him.
So now we could have done with that.
Another victory for Cupid.
Congratulations are in order.
Till you go away.
Now come back. I told you go away.
No! Go hit it when I want.
Meat ruined by the fire. Even the animals won't touch it.
Better this way. Here, take a bite.
May I?
It's much more tender this way.
Might as well try it, huh?
Bravo! Spark! Spark equals fire! Fire equals tender meat!
Only Jumbo sticks to his raw meat diet.
Maestro is busy making a cozy cradle. Why?
Because as you can see, time has made a mother of young Purette.
See! Gadget!
What's supposed to do with that?
Look closely. Each line means one day.
And this circle is the moon, which is growing full.
That is how we can predict freezing weather or the hunting season.
although to bring him back someone help the children much warmth coming from the sun lately
the birds have flown off and the animals are keeping their distance this is a fine model the
seasons just aren't what they used to be maestro not ripe yet suddenly snow another first for our
friends nice age is coming friends know going on is beyond me themselves now what's the plan having
something to eat pest and his men are on the prowl we're trapped but you go warm tables are turned
and passed his cock in his own ambush.
Follow.
Maybe they'll lead us to a better place.
First here.
In that case, the solution is to light a bonfire.
Dear boy.
For you.
The poor beast never even knew what hit him.
Do you know Hame, Maestro?
No, no, many thanks. I don't feel much like food.
You're a cat.
You would, son.
I always trade my charms for it.
Maestro.
Maestro?
Our friend Maestro, I fear, has left us.
Now he will embark upon a very long journey.
Farewell.
Say, let's put him underground, not leave him here.
To die a violent death in battle, by accident, or while hunting, this was normal.
To die of old age, now that was rare.
25,000 years before our time, Neanderthal man ended his 100,000 years as master of Europe
by disappearing without a trace.
Was his race meant to end here?
Was he killed by the intense cold, genetic mutation?
To this day, these questions remain unanswered.